led by uh
by john prescott so let me um
let me go ahead and and introduce uh
john uh while uh
while the panelists uh videos are being
pinned up
to the
to the screen
[Music]
okay so um
[Music]
um so john
is um
uh you know i i think john really needs
no introduction to this this audience um
he's um
he's uh the feynman professor of
theoretical physics at
cal tech he is the director of the
institute for quantum information and
mata
he's also the science coordinator for
this qsa uh
uh institute that i that i spoke of
um
you know in term in terms of uh uh
quantum computing uh
he's he's uh
he's a towering figure who's been
extraordinarily uh influential in
quantum computing both through
his um
his instinct for knowing what are the
important questions as well as through
his mentoring of this vast fraction of
students and postdocs
in the field
so um
so uh
really great to uh to welcome john
and um
[Music]
let's see uh
i'd like to
see if
uh sorry i was still sharing the screen
is it possible to to pin the the videos
at this point
all right our
panelists are
appearing
all right well thanks very much umesh
uh welcome everybody to quantum industry
day the first of two
panel discussions
as zumesh mentioned i'm a professor of
theoretical physics at cal tech i'm also
an amazon scholar
associated with the center for quantum
computing that
amazon has established
on the caltech campus
i'd like to quickly introduce our
panelists we have seven very interesting
people
representing seven companies
um
mike bierzuk is the
founder and ceo of cue control and also
professor of quantum physics and quantum
technology at the university of sydney
he
his company develops control solutions
in both hardware and software for
quantum technology and he continues to
operate his research group at the
university
jay gambetta is the ibm
fellow and vice president for quantum
computing at ibm
he's been at ibm for 10 years now
leading developments and super
superconducting quantum computing
nate gamelke is the cto and director of
technology at cuera
before that he was on the faculty of
penn state
uh cuera is developing the technology of
rydberg atoms in tweezer arrays
your adonis caranitas is the head of
quantum algorithms at qc where
and also the director of the paris
center for quantum computing
your dennis has made many contributions
to quantum algorithms and he's been
especially active recently in pursuing
the potential applications of quantum
machine learning
terry rudolph
is the co-founder of psy quantum and
professor of quantum physics at imperial
college london
sciquanum is developing silicon
photonics for quantum computing
steve sanders is the director of
engineering for
honeywell quantum solutions he's been at
honeywell for over 20 years working on a
variety
of engineering challenges and has been
part of honeywell's quantum effort
for about five years now and is matthias
here um
not sure he's joined us yet
but uh matthias troyer uh who i hope
will be joining us is a distinguished
scientist at microsoft
until 2019 he was professor of
computational physics at eth he's an
expert on classical and
quantum algorithms for simulating
quantum matter
so i'd like to start with jay
jay
already 15 years ago you were working on
transmonds
in superconducting quantum computing
back in your yale days
and transmonds have advanced a lot
since then thanks in part to innovations
at ibm
are we starting to see
those advances slowed down in your
opinion do you see signs that the
improvements in fidelity
for
transmonds are in multi-qubit devices in
particular
are reaching limits is it time to start
thinking about alternative approaches to
superconducting qubit design in your
opinion
thanks john um so
i i'll partially answer it uh positive
and negative in in in both ways
um the transmon is the most simplest
super conducting qubit you can make a
junction with
capacitor recently we've seen
still continued improvements with us uh
getting near a millisecond in coherence
right and you'll see uh you'll see that
emerging
into our larger devices in the next
couple of weeks
so if i look at it and i try and compare
the gate fidelities or the coherence no
it hasn't started slowing down so we
still think that we'll continue pushing
uh pushing those limits and keep pushing
them well into
the tens of milliseconds and the error
rates are small enough but on the other
side i totally support high risk high
reward type research and looking at
alternate alternative qubits in the
university lab
and especially if they're done in a way
where we could imagine putting them
inside a larger device that we make
but as far as ibm is concerned for the
time being you're going to ride the same
horse the transmon for some while yet
and expect to continue to see
improvements in performance and if you
are if you want to study coherence
you want to build the simplest thing you
can do
to it and the simplest thing you can do
is a capacitor in a junction
and when you can get the cues of that
even higher than the queues of
resonators
there is no reason to stop pursuing that
direction
whilst you keep pushing up the quality
now if things come in that can give us a
much more efficiency i would totally put
it in but it is a myth to think that the
coherence
of transmonds is less than others
okay that's very encouraging and along
the lines of uh where we're heading in
hardware development
uh i have a question for steve
uh
honeywell made a architectural decision
a few years back about what type of ion
trap are designed to pursue which is a
bit different than some other
groups and companies have decided you
are building micro fabricated traps with
multiple operating zones and moving the
ions around between those zones so what
what drove that decision and how far do
you think that can carry us
yes good question well uh when we began
this and thank you john and hello to
everybody um
well when we began this exercise five
years ago um
we certainly
believe that some of our strengths were
our micro factification capabilities we
believed that trapped ions would need to
take advantage of those
um
could start with you know large chains
of ions in single wells but we believe
that there were some pretty
restrictive limitations that you could
achieve with that
and believe that we could overcome many
of those with with these microfabricated
traps
today i think the evidence is pretty
good i mean we have our two commercial
systems online today
with 10 qubits and a volume a quantum
volume of 10 qubits 2 to the 10.
that approach gives you
very good gait fidelity we're running
typically in the 997 998 range
very low crosstalk
which in turn enables things like
mid-circuit measurement
and has enabled us to do some nice
things with quantum air correction demos
recently demonstrating all of the
functional steps needed to do a logical
qubit
um
you know qubit reuse which allows you to
reduce the number of qubits you need and
so forth so we thought there were a
number of important advantages that that
would offer and wanted to start tackling
those challenges right away
one of those challenges for example is
to go to two-dimensional traps
or commercial systems are based on
one-dimensional geometries
we do now have two-dimensional traps um
working uh
moving ions through junctions moving
even mixed species ions through
junctions um
so so we think there's a there's a lot
of runway there
certainly even two into the thousands of
physical qubits kind of range
so of course we're keeping our eyes on
on other approaches like
photonic links but we think this
approach has a lot of runway still
there seems to be a trade-off between
that high fidelity uh entangling gate
you've achieved and the speed of the
gates your gates are pretty slow
do you think uh at some point we're
going to care enough about uh
how long it takes to get to solution in
a quantum algorithm that will have to
have much faster ion trap gains
certainly that's important the depth one
circuit time is a little long for us and
we continue to push on that turns out
we're really not limited by the gate
time itself we're actually limited by
things like once you do the iron
transport
we want to cool them back down for
example
and so
we have a lot of work going on
fast and cool iron transport how do you
keep it cool even while you're moving it
quickly and then how do you cool it down
again quickly if it does heat up a
little bit
faster gates
faster transport so
all those things continue to be
you know big priorities and i think
again we have we have um
i think we can probably get quite a bit
of improvement in the next couple of
years actually
all right so continuing with our
hardware builders
uh nate we've seen some
impressive results lately from these
rydberg systems and simulating novel
states of matter and both in equilibrium
and far from equilibrium
uh
does cura envision
a gate-based a circuit-based approach
with the technology or do you think that
potential customers are going to find
value in in that type of quantum
simulation platform yeah so the answer
is yes yes to both so we are pursuing
both pathways
you know i think in the near term
neutral atoms have a good advantage in
terms of just being able to scale the
systems to very large size
and that means that we can attack
problems that are you know certainly
above the threshold where we can
classically simulate what these machines
will do
so you know we feel that the quantum
simulators are really kind of a unique
opportunity in the near term
there's a lot of scientific computing
goals that we think that we can tackle
you know basically out of the gate with
those machines
you know one of one of the big
challenges is how do you expose the
utility of that to people broadly and
you know encourage application
development in a space that really
requires to
put a very high intellectual
thinking cap on and try to figure out
how to map systems onto each other so
from that sense you know programmable
quantum simulators with with the
programmability that's increasing over
time that's a great pathway for making
sure that we're always doing something
which is unique
but also gets us into that range where
we can start to one day do universal
gate based computing think about error
correction those kinds of things
so i think you'll see in the next year
a lot of results not not just out of the
academic community but also at a cure
and the other
neutral item companies
pushing that that programmability up
getting gate addressing and really
thinking about it in the traditional
quantum computing context but at the
same time i think you'll you'll see a
storm of new results on on simulation
scientific computing
you expressed optimism about scaling
things up uh
do you see uh
you know
an obstacle in the short term to how big
a tweezer platform you can build and
operate
i mean you know it's it's
to some extent it's a question of how
big a machine we project is going to be
useful in the near term
so you know
obviously cold atom systems can build
quantum systems that are strongly
coherent and have have qubit numbers or
atomic numbers that are in the tens of
thousands if we want to um quantum
simulators may have made a lot of
progress in that regard
quantum gas microscopes and machines
that look like that but for quantum
computation you know obviously you want
to keep that system entangled over large
sizes uh it doesn't make a lot of sense
to really you know kind of build a
machine that's that's much bigger than
that so we're kind of staying at the
threshold
you know we're taking a broader view
about how to define you know the
intangible uh sample of the quantum
computer
um so you know ideas like quantum volume
are useful but uh when when you have
multi-cubic gates to exploit
it can be a little bit wider thinking
about how big that computer should be so
for now we've picked uh
qubit sizes of a couple hundred for that
reason and we'll stay ahead of where
coherence permits us to go
okay and going to terry uh
terry if i'm not mistaken you have at
times expressed some skepticism about
the prospects for scaling some of the
platforms and have advocated uh
photonics as the best approach
can you explain your reasons for that
skepticism as well as why you think
photonics is a more promising avenue
that's really putting me on the spot i
didn't realize i get that question i
have like a take a long time to go
through each different
architecture and
discuss you know there's there are very
good reasons to pursue as many
architectures as we can i think
but if you're
very focused on full fault tolerant
quantum computing getting to the order
of 10 to the 10 gates on hundreds of
logical cubits
i don't really see another option
for the photonics you know because the
challenge is kind of inverted that
the
you know the scaling part of what we do
is very easy by comparison to just the
production of a small entangled state
that
you know i'm pretty optimistic
about the sort of scaling part and yeah
the hard part for us is producing
something like a 10 to 20 cubit
entangled state on a reasonable
repetition rate like you know
a few hundred megahertz or gigahertz or
something like that and
you know the rest of it's
it's easy by
by
comparison to other challenges in the
field
um
and so you know we we've gone with what
we
think will get us to a machine that is
provably useful
and
i
you know one day i do think things like
how many toffley gates you can do in a
day and other sort of metrics
for comparing
different approaches to doing quantum
computing will be relevant
and you know in in those kinds of things
photonics also comes off pretty well if
you do a comparison and so
you know even if the very first quantum
computer isn't photonic i'm pretty sure
the ones in 50 years time will be
so i don't feel i'm
wasting my time out of academia at the
moment
we've been eagerly awaiting uh news
about uh sci-q's success at uh you know
creating entangled photon states are we
going to be hearing some good news soon
um
i guess it depends you know
as i said everything's a little bit
different right like we produce
well let's just say many billions of
photons a second
and they're very easily intangible by
putting them on a beam splitter so you
know if we came up with a metric
that was
you know good for our architecture would
be something like how much entanglement
in the space-time volume are you
producing and yeah you know we can
create a lot but it's just not our focus
is really on
fault tolerance and not just generic
entanglement creation and creating fault
tolerance entanglement as you know is a
different ball game right you've got to
be smart
you've got to have
just different
parameter regions of control and so
because the quantum part of what we do
is kind of trivial
compared to the sort of classical part
of what we do
i don't think it's uh particularly
useful for us to bang on about the
quantum stuff where people be like yeah
well that's easy for you guys
um so yeah i don't know some of these
are
down to just you know what's your your
sort of personal taste and how you
should
uh communicate
progress but you know i think we've
chosen a particular path that
people have some pretty good
understanding of what we're doing i
think
all right well that control is a good
segue to mike
cue control is developing
hardware agnostic
control solutions can you explain to us
why it makes sense
to address the control problem
in a platform independent way rather
than customizing it to
each hardware approach
yeah i mean i i guess to start we do we
do both right so we build tools that at
their core are hardware agnostic
um
it effectively starts with some
hamiltonian level model of your system
or the absence of a hamiltonian level
model
where all you're doing is representing
controllable variables in your system
whatever knobs they might be whether
they're the you know electrical currents
in uh in
thermal tuning for phase shifters in a
photonic circuit or they're the iq
modulation signals in a superconducting
circuit ultimately it's a knob we can
turn
what we try to build is solutions that
allow you to do robust quantum logic and
build autonomy and
use ai and machine learning techniques
in order to automate a lot of the
low-level control tasks that are
required for these systems like tune-up
and the like now all the tools at their
heart are agnostic
and and i think the motivation for that
is illustrated by the diversity of
opinions we see today on what is the
best pathway forward
but what we always do is uh you know to
use a software analogy we skin
the solutions like you can start with
android on a mobile phone and then make
the samsung skin or whatever in order to
suit the dominant needs of a particular
platform so for instance we'll take our
tools and we have very specific
solutions that we've deployed on ibm's
hardware for using say
deep reinforcement learning to design
the iq modulation waveforms that give
you uh error robust quantum logic aids
that only need to be retuned once a
month instead of once a day
and we have similar different approaches
from almer serengates in trapped ions
and the like but for us the motivation
is very much that starting today in the
era of small scale systems and looking
forward
through to full fault tolerant machines
we see that in in every step and in
every platform there's an essential need
for control and automation
and that's the the key problem that
we're trying to uh to address across all
the different platforms
some of the companies are developing the
full stack
but you have uh decided to occupy a
niche
but tying in to some of those bigger
companies so do you think there are
other such uh
you know areas where a company can uh
map out some territory and contribute to
the advance of the field but without uh
building the full stack
yeah i mean i think um
my my personal view having now become
the
you know gone from physicist to uh ceo
of a software company or more dominantly
software company is uh is that
there's a lot to learn from the software
industry where broadly coders software
engineers do as much as they can to
avoid writing code and instead focus on
bringing in third-party solutions or
existing solutions as much as as you
possibly can for efficiency
and um i think the the notion of
companies insisting on being full stack
and and meaning that they do that to the
exclusion of all other things i think
that will gradually uh melt away now
we already see a diversity of players i
mean uh qc where is is one such
organization that focuses at the top of
the stack you know application layer
uh our friends at zapata and uh and one
qubit do similar things uh and i think
you'll see more and more
uh opportunity for
solutions from the application layer and
the operating systems down through the
kinds of infrastructure software that uh
that we focus on where we're we're
closer to the hardware uh but i i do
think ultimately the stack will evolve
to have multiple players across many of
the different platforms
all right so having mentioned qc where
let's let's hear from your donnis
dinosaur
you have i i have heard you say and
actually i've quoted you from time to
time as saying quantum machine learning
is over hyped but underestimated
uh a pleasing uh
oxymoron
can you explain that both sides of it
how is it over hyped and also
underestimated
yeah
i guess you pay too much attention to
what i say
but let's see um
i think what's happening is is you know
something that
when you try to breach the gap between
basic research on one height and very on
one side and very you know
applications and real world problems on
the other side
then it's it's not very easy in the
sense that
in order to make something actually work
in the real world you have to obviously
start with some solid theoretical you
know idea and some solid algorithm but
then you have to do many things to to
take this theoretically beautiful
algorithm make it work on in real life
right
so to do that you may lose some of
you know the beautiful theorems that you
can prove about what this algorithm can
actually do right because you have to
to tweak it to make it work in practice
and this may not always be you know uh
let's say it's
it can be found upon at some point right
because you're losing this this
mathematical background that the
solid background that you have this is
when i say that it can be you know uh
underestimated from the point of view
that you know
you know it's you may not be able to
prove anything but as long as you have
some you start from something solid and
you try to build intuition and you try
to make it work in practice then this
might actually work right and
overestimate it in the sense that if you
don't really have to prove something
which is many times the case in machine
learning then you can also
claim many things that may not be based
on solid you know evidence let's say or
mathematical proofs so somehow it's it's
what i'm trying to do in the last few
years is kind of try to balance the two
the two things
right and try to bridge the
more theoretical work that i i was doing
in academia for the last 20 years
and the fact that you know i wanted to
ask a very specific question which was
how can we make these machines useful
right so you know and it's in this kind
of balance between the two that i think
that we really need to make an effort
and figure out how to make things work
well i'm wondering how delicate that
balance is you like some of our other uh
panelists are maintain a foot in
academia
as well as in the quantum industry is
that a stable situation
is there some tension between the two
between your academic and uh
in business
uh do
are there pressures that will tilt you
one way or the other it's a question i
guess that also applies to others
in the past
um
i mean
for me the decision to to try out to to
to also work in with a startup and not
solely uh at the university was
was a question of
you know
what do i need in order to say that at
least i made my best effort
to actually figure out if for example
these disk machines or the fault alarm
messages can actually have useful
applications right so what i needed was
like one
make sure that i'm working in the right
problems that the problems that people
actually want to solve right
and for that you need to have
connections with the industry and figure
out what are really the problems that
people solve and they cannot solve or
they would like to solve it right
the second is that
you know especially in this period where
the machines are extremely you know
difficult to use a noisy you need to
have access to the hardware to test
things out so i also needed to have
access to the hardware and actually many
different hardware because all of them
have different
you know pros and cons let's say
and the third is that you also want to
be in a research-oriented environment
right so kind of
how do you combine all these things well
in my
my side i went to a small startup that
does quantum algorithms as a priority
right
so we're research oriented we try to
find algorithms but we can't try to
connect it to
to problems that people want to solve in
practice so in that sense i don't see a
big difference between academia and
and being in a in a quantum company i
think
you know
there
as long as you have the right
environment you can do your work and
continue and make the best you can you
can be a professor three days a week and
a businessman three days a week and rest
on sunday and
everything works out you get you get
away with many things because you also
have the academic thing right like you
have to talk to
vc people less because you say no no i
cannot do these things i've never
learned you know so it's you know it
gives you a bit of a license to
to be a little different than a business
person right so that's
good well you made the good point that
you want to talk to real customers find
out what the problems are that they want
to solve
but that connects to kind of a broader
question which is
uh
some of the both
algorithms of people and and hardware
builders have customers
and uh
which are using their
services
why uh
what um
you know what is really incentivizing
them uh if as as far as we can tell is
currently the case
they can't really
yet with existing platforms
solve problems that they care about that
they couldn't solve using using
classical computers
um
well maybe it's a good question for jay
you've got lots and lots of customers
clamoring to use your
use your hardware
why don't they just wait until you have
a more powerful quantum computer that
can really solve their problems
it's a good question
um
honestly i think i see this as tools and
we're building tools that have more
capability a lot of our customers go
everywhere from education places
so in academic research
like michael for example is looking at
different types of controls as many
doing that so they get value out of
using these tools and exploring and then
a lot of businesses um they want to
start their quantum journey now they
don't want to wait and so they want to
get in early they want to learn how
these tools work and they want to see
where it's going and get an
understanding of it and we um our view
is to be transparent of where the
technology is but release an aggressive
roadmap of where we're going and and
allow them to come along on this journey
with us and many appreciate that
so but in a way you're pulled in two
directions right because you want to
uh
provide service for your customers but
you also want to make the big
innovations that will you know pay off
big time down the road are those things
in tension with one another or do you
see them as synergistic
we've designed our way of operating um
to keep them synergy like we have things
that we call core core devices which we
put work into making them uh reliable
stable up and learning all the details
of that
and then we have a way of making what we
call exploratory devices
uh be it we introduce fast reset um in
our last one of our last ones um
uh that allowed us to not have any loss
in uh coherence uh to be able to tool so
we deployed it straight away um we're
we're going to deploy 127 qubits
in next next month
and so you'll see um those come online
and they're good learning for us
um to see how they work
and uh so we we keep them going both and
with transparency to the user and the
clients
there isn't the attention because uh our
team also wants to use our exploratory
devices to do their research
do any of you want to venture in
so go ahead yeah
sorry i was just going to say i think
that our perspective on customers is
is a bit different in that sense that we
don't really see ourselves as building a
quantum computer
which we will then
open up to customers to use per se
you know we we do engage with customers
but
we imagine you know we're going to be a
quantum company with a quantum computer
we want to solve
problems that we think are important and
generate
value for our shareholders you know
solving
generating ip and solving things that we
think are societally important and
that's a big motivator for a lot of the
engineers in our company that
that they you know they're not just
building a computer that's kind of
much of much less people are from the
silicon industry but they're doing
something that they think
uh you know working
on the right sorts of problems they can
really change the world and that's a
good motivation certainly one of my
motivations you know to go the thing
with life was a lot simpler back in
academia than it is
here and
but i think you know we have an
obligation if we think we can do this we
should be doing it
i think
motivation with business model we of
course have the same motivation but your
path to get there depends on it
well how long has that passed do any of
you have uh
an opinion you're willing to share about
uh
how far the world is from a commercially
relevant quantum computer i don't mean
in the sense that customers will pay to
use it because that's happening now
but one which will actually solve
problems of considerable value in
business it can't be solved
by other means is it still a long road
to go
i i think i'm still enough of a
scientist to say that that's an open
question
we have hypotheses about how to get used
um
that that's already pretty good uh being
able to predict when when that
performance is gonna come like
you know i i think we need to do the
experiment to build out the business and
get the customers in the door see how
they're using it react to that and drive
it home
and that's that's likely to be a
long road but who knows maybe we'll find
it it's right around the corner because
we didn't think about the right idea
before we built these things
and it's going to be a fun journey to be
honest
it's going to be fun i guess that's why
we're all doing it right everybody
having fun yes
as an algorithms guy
jordan do you uh
do you see promise in so-called uh noisy
intermediate scale
quantum technology are we going to be
able to uh solve interesting problems
with it in your opinion
yeah another one of this open questions
i guess
i think what is important is is to to
make sure that
we kind of try our best to make them you
know to make something useful out of
these machines because these are the
machines that we have and we're gonna
have for some time
so to me the question is
how can we make the best effort to make
them useful right if we actually manage
to do it in the end that's okay we will
see right of course it's not the wasted
as we said the journey is not wasted
like making an algorithm work from a
million cubits with to a thousand cubits
is also very useful even if you have
volatile and qubits right because we're
not going to have billions volatile from
from the get-go either
so try to to close the timeline whether
it is on the scale or for the fault on
the computer i think it's it's very
important if we manage from the
algorithmic side to
to come up with new algorithms that can
deal better with noise or that can use
fewer qubits or more shallow circuits
and things like that this really
advances the timeline to useful stuff
for with a knot and i'm willing to do
the best i can because as terry said i
think
yeah we have a responsibility to to try
our best
let's shift gears a little bit
we hear a lot about the need to
develop a quantum workforce
people who are trained to enter this
field
for which there is an increasing
appetite
is that a challenge for your companies
now do you have trouble finding the
people that you need to fill roles uh
in your companies and and what kind of
training do you want to see
that will uh fit your needs
you
you have an opinion steve
i do it certainly is a challenge um
i think for you know one one good way to
see that is if you look at the oak ridge
uh
newsletter every sunday that comes out
you see about 150 rolls posted for
quantum scientists quantum engineers and
you know the the seven of us on the
phone and
maybe three or four other places are all
in competition
you know to fill those same 150 rolls um
so it's certainly a challenge
we look for atomic physicists the good
news is we're located in boulder
colorado where there's a pretty good
supply of those
but
right now finding electrical engineers
photonics people
they're all in in high demand in short
supply and
you know we could certainly use more of
all of those
i think
very broadly a lot of the general skills
are in extremely high demand and that
means that everybody in on this call
would be at some level competing for the
same class of people i mean our
particular strategy focused on building
really niche capability in quantum
control engineering and so we compete
for a slightly different market but
maybe to your to your second point john
what is it that we're looking for
um
you know i had i had written about this
you and i talked about this briefly uh
some months ago
i think the thing we're looking for most
is people with experience and research
and
i say that to contrast with a growing
trend that i see in the in the you know
education workforce development that
really talks about well we're just going
to make a master's program that is so
ideally suited for the quantum industry
and everybody will flow through that
um and and there are certainly cases in
which that may be appropriate like some
of them like that the etihad one is
really fantastic for people who want to
work in superconducting qubits
and there are similar examples around
the world
i think broadly what we find most
attractive in good candidates is a
demonstrated ability to do deep research
and that's not you know a one semester
project that's that's doing two years of
at least masters or more of uh
really exploratory research because it's
their creativity that we find most
valuable and then the rest of it i think
we can we can teach on the job if you're
not familiar with
i don't know tensorflow you can learn
that if you're not familiar with some
particular
tenet of robust control theory you can
learn that but if you don't have
experience in solving hard problems
and understanding what it takes to uh to
overcome some of the real challenges we
face in the laboratory that that's
something that's very difficult to teach
on the job
this being the uh the simon's institute
for the theory of computing i presume a
lot of our
viewers are theorists anybody want to
hire theorists
looking for those too
all right that's
that's good to see
i guess we're kind of getting to the end
of our scheduled time we should probably
give the audience uh a chance can we
push a few minutes uh
further umesh before we wind up um yes
uh let's let's do that um what we have
after this is a break on gabatown so
let's let's cut into this and
actually let me also say that we have a
moderator um
uh who's who's checking the the chat and
the q a
uh so if anybody from the audience has
questions please please post it on that
so our moderator is um is andrea uh
called angelo he's he's a first talk at
the simons institute so so he'll be
looking through through these questions
and asking you to unmute and
and ask your questions
before we go to the audience just one
more thing this does anybody want to
make a prediction about
where we will be say 10 years from now
how do you anticipate the evolution of
the industry
that's a good one for you jay
i think i've been
pretty vocal of where i see
what we're going to do over the next few
years we tend to underestimate
uh in the future and overestimate
how hard things are in here
i'm
i'm
i'm optimistic i always am so i'm hoping
we're at the stage where we have
large-scale
machines that are using error correction
and terry
i i was just going to say i think that
the history of classical computing told
us that until we had a classical
computer in hand
you know you had turing doing stuff on
piece of paper without the actual
device we wouldn't have pokemon in
minecraft cheering was not going to come
up with
you know important applications like
that was he so until we really have
quantum computers in hand i think we
actually don't really know
what their impact will be because so
much of algorithm development has to be
heuristic and tested out and you know is
this thing converging or not that's how
the real
classical world of algorithms works and
so in 10 years time
i'm really hoping that we're in that
world where
we can't really judge what their impact
is because we don't have them to play
with and really you know
run algorithms that you know proper
large scale algorithms with and so yeah
it's exciting but
i think be very naive to really predict
what what that will involve
[Music]
i wanted to add just that uh i'm
extremely optimistic about the shape of
the industry in part because of the
level of
end user engagement of people who want
to build and want to use quantum
computers as much as those of us on the
call like to to build and optimize them
uh and to me the best evidence for that
actually has come through kovid
when when things started looking pretty
bad in in march april 2020
um
many many people predicted another
call for the quantum winner we've had a
lot of calls for quantum winners
um
one motivation could have been that
enterprise was paying out of corporate
responsibility budgets or exploratory
research budgets and that would just dry
up and that would be the end of it as
soon as there was a risky economic
environment and that simply did not
materialize right we've seen a doubling
and tripling down
of end user engagement in the field and
i think that portends uh you know
ongoing growth that's going to support
the technical developments that
everybody on this call is uh working so
hard on
well john i'm i'm glad that you picked
ten years uh because i think we could
come back in ten years and have the same
panel reassembled
and and i think that we'll all survive
that and i think that we probably will
all be doing the same thing
uh quantum computing
but i hope that we will be speaking a
language um that you know we'll
recognize parts of it today
but there will be you know new words in
that lexicon that we discovered
by making these these machines big
enough that we have to study how they
work
and you know i think that's where real
algorithms uh discovery is gonna start
is once once that machine is really a
studyable beast and it's it's almost a
fundamental science of itself
and i think that's a great place to come
back to the simons institute ten years
later and see how it's how it's gone
all right it's a date i'll expect you
all in 10 years i'm glad that none of
you are anticipating that the field will
crash and burn in that time interval
i see one question hoping microsoft
exchange doesn't survive 10 years so
don't send me a calendar invite
let's go the old one
i see one question in the chat it's kind
of a technical one uh for nate
uh i said i'll paraphrase it's about to
what extent uh you know should we be
concerned about spontaneous emission as
a fundamental limit on uh on rydberg
platforms
oh uh yeah i mean
definitely it's it's it's in the air
budget um it's it's something that we
think about a lot it really depends on
how you're running your quantum computer
so uh there are two different kinds of
spontaneous mission that we worry about
one is from the excited state in the
rydberg state we also excite to that
state with two photon transitions so
there's offers and transitions to an
intermediate state uh both of those
contribute the one the one everybody
should probably worry about more is that
rydberg's state lifetime
there are plenty of tricks to play in in
the future there are also long-lived
ridburg states as well
so-called circular river states so you
know i think that's going to be
always part of the design of the machine
it's it's going to be something that
that we think about uh we're always
going to need bigger battery lasers to
get farther off resonance with that
intermediate state uh and i think we're
always going to be choosing new river
states to work with just to maximize
that lifetime
okay anybody else on the 10-year
question
you've been a very lovely panel i think
we're already encroaching on our uh our
break time um
uh john there's one more question in the
in the chat in the chat um oh sorry i
think ilana
uh
from oxford quantum circuits
ask how do you see the role of
government for the quantum industry
development what helps what doesn't
well maybe weigh in very briefly from
the highwall side i think one thing we
that does not help is a lot of
restriction
um you know certainly the us
government's been considering export
restrictions and itar restrictions and
so forth and
um you know we've been kind of working
through our government relations side to
to argue for
you know keeping things open as much as
possible because we think there's just
so much
so much innovation that needs to happen
um
and it would just be too early to shut
all that down so
from our perspective we really think
it's important to keep a free-flowing
collaborative environment
so i can add i i agree completely with
that i see three things the government
should keep doing r d i think this is
fundamentally important i'd love to see
more put into algorithm work
i would say secondly um
i very much want to see
the government taking a role in
acquiring what i would call
without lack of a better word commercial
grade systems it helps industry keep
going
and then the third obviously is um the
workforce development which you touched
on
and if the government can help us as a
community address all three of them as
well as export
i think that would be very good for
industry
yeah i'll give i'll give one positive
one negative the positive is uh
government is customer is an extremely
powerful concept uh when i was working
in dod this was something that we saw uh
spawn very valuable young companies just
by you know darpa buying technology and
then it becoming acquisition through
other services
on the negative
um i'm i'm a little nervous about
government becoming
you know shifting away from funding
basic science and moving to create uh
what you can pejoratively call
grantrepreneurs
uh commercial organizations that exist
for no reason other than to apply for
government grants i don't think that's a
successful outcome
for the industry i think we can keep
that in in the university and national
lab sector and instead let you know
commercial organizations uh bloom in the
private sector
well there's a related question which is
what's the role of academic researchers
as
investment pours into
both industry and
national labs
we're still going to need a lot of
innovations do you see
you know the universities of course
they're going to be providing the
workforce that you guys are hungry for
but uh you're not going to come up with
all the ideas yourselves are you
thank you that was the first question
you asked me john i think them doing
high risk high reward is essential for
us to make progress
yeah i'd underscore that
very good well i'm glad to uh
to see uh everyone is optimistic about
the future
and uh this was really interesting i
wish we had more time
but uh we'll we'll have a panel of fresh
faces uh later in the day and i guess
now it's uh it's network time is that
right umesh yeah yeah well thanks a lot
uh to the panel and especially thanks to
you john for uh
a really stimulating set of questions uh
so so i believe kelani has put the
gather town link in in the chat in case
you missed it so um
yeah let's um
let's meet up there and then
and then we'll meet back here at 11 30.
everyone
all right thanks everyone thank you
thank you
and so yes we invite you to go to gather
town which is a